let's say we've got a company here that
has exactly let's say that it has
exactly four shares just to simplify
things obviously very few companies have
only four shares but this will simplify
the explanation and let's say that each
of those shares right now they are
trading in the market or I guess we
could say the last transaction that's
occurred in trading in these shares they
are trading at two dollars a share
two dollars two dollars per share so the
market is saying that each of those
shares are worth two dollars there's a
four of these shares in total and we're
going to assume that this company has no
liabilities so the shareholders just
outright own the assets so if there's
four of these shares times two dollars
the market is saying that this company's
assets are worth exactly eight dollars
eight dollars right over here
eight dollars the the asset value of the
market value of the assets is the same
thing as a market cap in this case
because we have no liabilities now what
I want to think about is what happens if
the company wants to raise some more
money let's say that they want to let's
say that they want to issue some more
shares and sell them to raise some money
to buy a factory or whatever so they
literally do is the board approves for
them to literally create two more shares
the board they create two more shares so
now they have a total of six shares
outstanding and then the company goes
they get an investment banker and they
do a secondary offering in the public
markets and they sell these incremental
shares and they're able to sell them
let's just say for simplicity simplicity
at two dollars per share at two dollars
per share normally when you increase the
supply a little bit you won't get quite
what the previous market value was but
you get roughly two dollars a share two
dollars a share for simplicity and by
selling two shares that it just created
for two dollars a share the company is
able to raise another another four
dollars so the whole reason why I'm
going through this exercise is to ask a
question did die Lucian did die Lucian
take place and there's different ways to
thinking when you think about dilution
it's like you could imagine if you have
a sweet syrup and if you add water to it
it becomes less
sweet as each kind of cube of that water
each drop of that water has less sugar
in it you've diluted it and so there
seems to be an analogy here we now have
more shares for the same company and it
is true if you were the owner of this
share over here before before the share
offering up here you owned 25% of the
company after the share offering you own
1/16 so not 1/16 1/6 so after you own
1/6 or approximately 16% so it looks
like the percentage that you own of the
company has been diluted and that's true
to some degree but sometimes the
dilution takes on another meaning that
somehow because more shares are being
used it for the ownership of the same
company that maybe these shares are
worth less and that's the one thing I
want to challenge there is dilution in
the percentage you own but there is not
diluted in what the shares are worth
because before if you had four shares
representing something that is worth
eight dollars now you have six shares
representing something that is twelve
dollars because the company didn't just
issue these shares and get nothing in
return for it it got four dollars of
cash you can't debate the value of four
dollars four dollars or worth four
dollars so now the assets of the company
are worth twelve dollars so you have
twelve dollars of assets no liabilities
six shares twelve dollars divided by six
years is still two dollars a share so
the value per share has not been diluted
just the percentage of the company that
you happen to own